in Presidente
la Saluda aperto the sitting is open
lordy DiGiorno Eric on our agenda we
will have the statement by the present
of the Commission on the State of the
Union and without any further ado I
shall get the floor off the president of
the Commission jean-claude Juncker
Monsieur laplace's our president present
an office in the council honorable
members good morning
sometimes history who's discreetly the
careful steps when we're talking about
the work of a commission which only has
a five year period to make some
substantial change over such a short
period of time you can't bring about a
sea change in the state of affairs the
current Commission like its predecessors
there's an episode a brief moment in
time in the long history of the European
Union our time is not yet to come in our
Commission's are not yet going to take
stock before you of everything we've
done over the last four years on the
contrary I will tell you that work will
continue over the coming months to
ensure that our imperfect European Union
becomes and for more perfect every day
we still have things to do which is what
I wish to discuss with you this morning
No
no satisfaction modesty turning smile
results that's the approach of our
commission as we look at our agenda over
the coming months sometimes history in
the true sense of the word thrust itself
into the life of nations without any
prior warning that's what happened at
the time of World War one in 1914 it
caught the the continent off guard it it
was a a sunny calm optimistic year in
1913 in 1913 Europeans were expecting to
live through a lasting peace and yet a
fratricidal war descended on Europe the
next year I'm referring to that period
not just because or rather not because
I'm suggesting that we're on the verge
of a similar catastrophe in Europe the
European Union is a guarantee of peace
let's be happy that we live on a
continent of peace a continent which
enjoys peace thanks to the European
Union
yes that don'tdon't and so let us show
more respect to the European Union
let us not sully its image let us defend
our way of life our way of being let's
embrace a type of patriotism that's not
directed at all against others and let
us decry knee-jerk nationalism which
attacks others and seeks scapegoats
rather than looking for solutions which
will allow us to coexist better
[Applause]
the founding principle of the Union No
More war never again this informs our
lies and those who everyone around us
what is the State of the Union today in
2018 Europe has very much got past the
economic racial crisis which hit us
coming from elsewhere and had a very
brutal impact on us as brothers we've
had new 12 million jobs created since
2014 the economy is growing that's more
than the number of people living in
Belgium never and we had so many people
239 million men and women at work in
Europe youth unemployment stands at
fourteen point eight percent that figure
is still too high but it's the lowest
level since 2000 investment has come
back to Europe thanks in particular to
the European fund for strategic
investment which
some fewer and fewer are calling the
younger plan that has generated
attention billion worth of public and
private investment and we're on target
for 400 billions worth and then increase
after years which it must be said were
painful years following unprecedented
social problems Greece has made a
success of its program and is back on
its feet I pay homage once again to the
Herculean efforts of the people an
effort that others in Europe has still
not acknowledged sufficiently I have
always as you know defended Greece its
dignity its role in Europe and in
particular its continued membership of
the eurozone and I'm still proud of that
Europe has also reasserted its trade
position it's a global trade power this
is proof if ever there was of the need
to pull sovereignty the European Union
today has trade agreements with 70
countries taken together we account for
40% of world GDP the trade agreements
I'm talking about are very often being
called in question wrongly they enable
us to export high european food safety
standards around the world as well as
workers rights environmental standards
and consumer law standards when last
July during a dangerous period
international tension I visited both
Beijing and Tokyo as well as Washington
in one week I was able to speak in my
capacity as president of Commission
on behalf of the largest single market
in the world on behalf of the Union
which accounts for fifth of the total
world economy a union which is prepared
to defend its values and its interests I
represented Europe as an open continent
but not one that we will hand over I was
able to to set out on a position in
detail in principle and I was able to
achieve powerful results for our
citizens and our firms when we are
united we Europeans as a union have
become a force to be reckoned with that
you cannot do without some in Europe one
happy with the agreement I reached with
the person Trump some were surprised by
it but that there shouldn't be no
surprise whenever Europe speaks as one
we can impose our position on others
where necessary Europe must act as one
we demonstrated this with our ceaseless
efforts to defend the Paris climate
agreement we as Europeans want to leave
a cleaner planet to coming generations I
agree with our energy commissioners
analysis of the co2 emission cuts for
2030 they're scientifically right and
politically necessary
the terrible events of this summer have
brought home not just a farmers the
importance of our efforts to safeguard
future for coming generations now of
course you may choose to ignore the
climate challenge look clear the way we
in the Commission and you empowerment
must look towards the future
ladies and gentlemen the clock is still
ticking
the world is a more volatile the
challenges before our continued up
growing day after day and so we cannot
ease up in our efforts even for one
second as we seek to build a more united
and stronger Europe Europe can export
its stability as we did with our
successive enlargements as far as I'm
concerned those enlargements have been
and remain success stories because we've
managed to bring together European
geography and history but efforts still
remain to be made we need a forthright
definition of our attitude towards the
accession of Western Balkan countries
otherwise others will take it upon
themselves to shape our immediate
neighborhood let us look around us and
see what's happening at this time in
Syria in a blip
the cause events should be a source of
great immediate concern to us all we
cannot remain silent in the face of an
impending humanitarian disaster which is
a disaster foretold the Syrian conflict
shows us how the international order
which Europeans have taken advantage of
since World War two and has increasingly
been called into question furthermore in
today's world Europe can no longer rest
assured that the commitments entered
into in the past
will so be respected in the future
yesterday's alliances may no longer be
tomorrow's alliances as I was saying
today's world needs a strong united
Europe Europe working for peace trade
agreements and stable monetary
arrangements even if others elsewhere
are all too inclined to resort to a
commercial or monetary warfare I don't
like which shirt Thanks with no regard
father's interests I remain a convinced
multilateral list if Europe better
realizes its political power its
economic power and sometimes it's the
military power of it its component
nations we will no longer have to be the
global payer alone whether we are still
willing to pay
but we have to be global players to say
that I don't protocol all they peed in
forest that's why it despite strong
resistance at the time as of 2014 i
relaunched the European defense Union
that's why in the coming months the
Commission will continue its work on the
European Defense Fund and permanent
structured cooperation in defense to
make them fully operational
I should add a point of detail which i
think is rather important in this
context we will not be militarizing the
European Union what we are seeking it's
great responsibility and independence
because only a strong united Europe will
be in a position to defend our citizens
from internal and external threats it
tourism or climate change only a strong
united Europe can save jobs in an open
interconnected world only a strong
united Europe will make it possible for
us to rise to the challenge of global
digitalization we Europeans because we
are the largest market in the world
we'll be able to set standards later
climate standards while upholding our
citizens conditions of of life provided
we are united a strong united Europe
well now it's Member States to reach for
the stars thanks to our Galileo program
Europe is still in the space race
no single member state would have been
able to launch these satellites that 400
million users around the world are
already benefiting from no member center
on the earth
Galileo is a success story primarily a
European success story without Europe
there would be no Galileo let's be proud
of that
president geopolitics tells us that the
valley founding for Europe's sovereignty
Europe has to embrace its destiny Europe
has a capacity to influence world
affairs Europe must increasingly be a
sovereign player in international
relations European sovereignty derives
from the national sovereignty of our
Member States it does not replace what
properly lies within the national
purview my polling zonte were necessary
we strengthened all our component
nations and regions that's part and
parcel of belonging to the European
Union European sovereignty will never be
directed against others Europe must
remain a tolerant open continent will
remain so Europe will never become a
fortress turning its back on the world
in particular the suffering part of the
world Europe must and will remain a
multilateral continent because the world
belongs to everyone not just the few
tell it'll see lawsuit is election or or
polymer up in and that's what's at stake
in European elections in May 2019 in the
250 days between now and then we must
get across to our citizens the evidence
that when we act together the European
Union can achieve results and it
respects the commitments we entered into
at the beginning of our period of office
between now and the European elections
we must show that Europe is able to
overcome differences between the North
and the South the East and the West
the European Union Europe is too small
to split itself into two today and for
tomorrow we have to show clearly that
together east west south and north we're
able to plant the seeds of a more
sovereign Europe president distinguished
members in may 20 2019 there will be
elections the citizens of Europe won't
be interested in what the Commission is
proposing but it will interest them that
that the companies pay their taxes where
they make their profits
the availa Valen voters want a lot from
you not all of you I know the voters
want to know know that the Commission
proposal will rapidly become a reality
those who want that a right if Europeans
in 2019 if they want they won't be very
interested in what the Commission does
on plastics if the Europeans if we want
to convince them we won't need a
European law which cements the ban on
plastics we all declare in fine speeches
that we want to be more ambitious in big
issue issues and less ambitious and
smaller things in 2029 teen the
Europeans won't applaud if twice a year
we have we have to continue to change
the clocks to twice a year we need to
change this business of changing the
clocks the Member States based on
subsidiarity should decide whether their
citizens should live in summer or winter
time we expect that council and
Parliament say this in the same way and
we'll make sure the regional single
market conformed solutions will be found
time is pressing
in the months ahead we should work
closer together so what we promised in
2014 can be delivered in good time too
for the European elections when we
started we promised to deliver told
signal market better mantra Union a
banking Union Affairs single market an
energy policy a comprehensive migration
policy and union of safety and security
at least most of us undertook that the
social dimension of Europe shouldn't be
in second place it should should be
treated more seriously the Commission
they all the initiatives that we
announcing the Commission in 2014 will
put on the table
half of them were already adopted by
council and Parliament 20% well-advanced
and 30% are stuck in some difficult
negotiations I don't accept that the
Commission is responsible for all the
faults itself of course there have been
shortcomings our proposals are well
known in particular when it comes to
refugees and migration they should be
adopted and implemented I won't allow in
future I know this will happen that the
Commission is made the sole scapegoat
scapegoats exist in all institutions at
least of them in the Commission and the
Parliament
and leadership
front asleep ghost to being a security
Union the Ian's expect quite rightly
protects them so on the Commission is
proposing new rules today to counter
terrorist propaganda and to take heed F
external borders must be protected more
effectively so we're proposing that the
number of border agencies from the
finance from the European budget by 2020
will be ten thousand we're making a
proposal to extend the European refugee
agency they need support when it comes
to processing asylum applications in
line with the Geneva Convention we're
making a proposal for the return of
illegal migrants I propose I repeat my
wish in Parliament which is a call to
open legal routes for migration into
Europe we need qualified migrants the
Commission proposals on this have been
on the table for some time so please
implement them
president ladies and gentlemen I would
like to talk about the future as well
and with air for must speak of Africa
Europe's twin continents by 2050
Africa's population will number 2.5
billion one in four people on earth will
be African we need to invest more in our
relationship with the nations of this
great and noble continent and we have to
stop seeing the Africa EU relationship
through the sole prism of development
aid such an approach is inadequate and
is humiliating for Africa Africa does
not need charity
it needs a true and balanced partnership
and Europe needs this partnership just
as much in preparing my speech today I
spoke with my African friends notably
Paul Kagame the chairperson of the
African Union and we agreed that
donor-recipient relations are a thing of
the past and we agreed that reciprocal
commitments are the way forward we want
to build a new partnership with Africa
Commission Papa's overly today we are
proposing a new alliance between Europe
and Africa an alliance for investment
and sustainable jobs this alliance as we
see it would help create up to 10
million jobs in Africa over the next
five years and we want to create a
framework that brings more investment to
Africa and we are not starting from
scratch our external investment plan
which was launched two years ago will
mobilize
over forty four billion euro in both in
public and private sectors the projects
which are in the pipeline will be to the
tune of 24 billion euro we want to focus
our investment where our actions make a
real difference by 2020 the EU would
have supported 35,000 African students
and researchers through the Erasmus
program by 2027 this figure should reach
a hundred and five thousand trade
between Africa and Europe is important
is significant 36 percent of Africa's
trade is with the European Union but
trade between us is not enough
unconvinced that we also have to make
progress on other agreements and to have
a continent to continent economic
partnership between equal partners and
move towards a free trade agreement
another issue but I see a strong need
for the Union for leadership is brexit I
will not enter into the details of the
negotiations which are being masterfully
emptied by my friend Michelle Bonnie he
works on the basis of a unanimous
position confirmed time and again by the
27 member states however allowed me to
recall three principles which should
guide our work on waxes in the months to
come
first of all we respect of course the
British decision to leave our union know
but we regard it deeply as you are but
we also asked the British government to
understand
that someone who leaves the union cannot
be in the same privileged position as a
member state as a member state if you
leave the Union you are of course no
longer part of our single market and
certainly not only in parts
secondly European Commission this
Parliament and all other member states
will always show loyalty and solidarity
with Ireland when it comes to the Irish
pot this is why we want to find a
creative solution that prevents a hard
border in Northern Iowa and we will
defend all the elements of the Good
Friday Agreement it is waxing that which
making the border more visible in
Northern Ireland it's not the European
Union Berkeley after the 29th of March
2019
the United Kingdom will never be an
orderly third country for us the United
Kingdom will always be a very close
neighbor and path in political economic
and security terms in the past month
when we need unity in Union Whitten was
at our site driven by the same values
and principles of all other Europeans
this is why I welcome Prime Minister's
permission-based proposal to develop an
ambitious new partnership for the future
after we accept we agree with the
statement made in checkers that the
starting point for such a partnership
should be a free-trade area between the
United Kingdom and the opinion on the
basis of these principles
the Commission's negotiators mainly my
good friend Michelle Bonnie stands ready
to work day and night to reach a deal we
owe it to our citizens and our
businesses to ensure the United
Kingdom's withdrawal is orderly and that
with stability afterwards it will not be
the commission that will stand in the
way of this madam a Monsieur ladies and
gentlemen members between now and the
European elections and between now and
the summit that will take place in the
month of May of next year in Romania a
lot of work remains to be done and we'll
have to convince our citizens that we
share the same purpose of our European
Union in Serbia we need to make sure
that we get things right
people want certainty they expect a
clear message and don't want half
measures to be taken so let's not give
them those then and this is all part of
the European agenda enroute to see you
in Serbia we'll have to ratify the
partnership agreement between the EU and
Japan and we'll have to enter into that
agreement for economic reasons but also
for geopolitical meetings between now
and Sibiu we'll have to organize an
agreement on principle for the post-2020
EU budget and we need to give young
Europeans an opportunity to make the
most of what the Erasmus programme has
to offer and we need to make sure that
enough money is available for
and we'll have to decide on that matter
as we will have to decide on others
other matters and if we want to give our
researchers and startups more
opportunities and prevent funding gaps
costing jobs we will have to decide on
the budget before the elections now
without militarizing the European Union
if we want to increase defense spending
by a factor of 20 again we will have to
decide on this before the elections if
we want to increase our investment in
Africa by 23% again we must decide
quickly heads of state ministers MVPs
national members of parliament we always
hear that we can't decide on these
matters before the elections because
that would lead to a democratic crisis I
say no it's normal in a democracy to
have elections and it's also normal to
take certain decisions before those
elections by next year
we also have to develop the
international role of the euro which is
now existed for 20 years and this in
spite of the criticism that has been
leveled at it the euro has been
successful it's the second global
currency after the dollar sixty
countries in one way or another have
pegged their currency to the euro but we
need to do more to make sure that our
single currency can play its full role
on the international scene and recent
developments have highlighted the need
to
deepen our monetary union and the
Commission has a lot of proposals that
say it wants to adopt we must and will
go further it's an aberration to have
three billion dollars worth of energy
imports of the year that's 80 percent
when only a small part of that comes
from the it comes from the United States
and it's an aberration to see that
European companies are buying European
planes in dollars and not in Euro and
that's something we will have to change
as well as on parochial this is why the
Commission and before the end of the
year will present initial initiatives to
strengthen the international role of the
euro the euro must become the active
instrument of a new and more sovereign
Europe we must of course first put our
own house in order by strengthening our
economic and monetary union which is
what we have already started to do
without a strengthened economic and
monetary union we won't be able to
achieve this we have to complete our
economic and monetary union so that the
euro can become stronger and still on
the road to Scipio I would like to make
a tangible progress when it comes to
strengthening our foreign policy we need
to improve our ability to speak with one
voice when it comes to foreign policy it
is not right that our union silenced
itself at the United Nations humor
it's canceled when it came to condemning
human rights abuses by China and this
because one member state opposed it that
is just one amongst many examples I
could give you see that as awkward I
killed although to me and that's the
reason why the Commission again would
propose to you that call us fight
majority voting is used on matters of
foreign policy sir epidermis earth I
would repeat the message that I set out
in detail last year and we will be
putting forward a number of proposals so
that in certain areas not a all areas of
foreign policy we can move towards
qualified majority voting the treaty as
it stands allows the EU to take a
decision on this basis and I think the
time has now come to use this lost
treasure of the Lisbon Treaty and I
think we should be able to decide on
certain matters by qualified majority
and I also think that in relation to
certain tax matters we should be able to
decide by qualified majority is not for
deal not to the fast song mr. president
we have disagreements between
governments and between institutions
increasingly there are disagreements
heated exchanges amongst government
institutions are becoming more and more
common but the tone is not only worrying
when it comes to political discourse but
it is also true of the way some seek to
shut down debate altogether by targeting
media and journalists Europe must always
be a place where freedom of press is
possible and is not called into question
too many of our journalists are
intimidated attacked or even murdered
nearly up the democracy we cannot have
democracy without Free Press
[Applause]
merci topology comes out of the blue
thank you for your applause that gives
me an opportunity to drink try again
didn't waver in fashion in general
ladies and gentlemen we must revive the
lost art of compromise they compromise
does not mean a weakness or a
sacrificing of our convictions and the
Commission will resist any attack on the
rule of law and we continue to be very
concerned by the developments in some of
our member states article 7 must be
applied whenever the rule of law is
threatened
I said they got the privilege first
vice-president Timmerman's is doing a
remarkable job of defending the rule of
law but all too often he stands alone in
defending the rule of law and the whole
Commission and I personally support him
fully
Yap well surely cat and then there is
one point on which we have to be very
clear and that is the judgments from the
court of justice which must be respected
and implemented the European Union is a
community of law and respecting the rule
of law and abiding by court decisions
are not an option but an obligation mr.
president
vulnerable members of the European
Parliament friends I started the speech
it will be my last speech but it's my
last State of the Union address by
talking about history history which in a
small way covers our mandate and of
course in a wider sense covers our time
here and we are all responsible for the
Europe of today and we must all take
responsibility for the Europe of
tomorrow such as history Parliament's
and commissions come and go
Europe is here to stay but for Europe to
become what it must
there are several lessons to be learnt
Europe can no longer be a spectator or a
mere commentator of international events
Europe must be an active player and must
become an architect of
tomorrow's world there is a strong
demand for Europe throughout the world
and to meet such high demands Europe
would have to speak with one voice on
the world stage and amongst nations
Europe's voice must be heard clearly
federica mogherini has made Europe's
diplomacy more coherent it's more can
hear it than it's ever be but let us not
slide back into the incoherence of
competing and parallel national
diplomacy's Europe's diplomacy must be
conducted in the singular
and from now on in I would like us to
make more efforts to bring together the
east and west of Europe it is time we
put an end to the sorry spectacle of a
divided Europe our continent and those
who brought an end to the Cold War
deserve better I would like the European
Union to take better care of its social
dimension to those who ignore the
legitimate concerns of workers and small
businesses putting our society at risk
and it is time that we proclaimed the
gothenburg social summit
into law I would like for next year's
elections to be a landmark for European
democracy I would like to see the
spittin cotton candy dart in process
repeated which is a small step forward
for European democracy for me this
process will be made more credible once
we have transnational lists and I hope
that that will be in place for the
elections in 2024
but above all I would like us to say no
to unhealthy nationalism and to say yes
to enlightened packages and we should
never forget that the papillote ISM of
the 21st century is twofold both
European and national and they are not
mutually exclusive as the French
philosopher Blaise Pascal said I like
things that go together
in order to stand on its own two feet
Europe and its nations must move forward
as one to love Europe is to love its
Nations to love your nation is to love
Europe patriotism is a virtue unchecked
journalism is both riddled with poison
and deceit
on annual that's not food there
in short we must remain true to
ourselves the trees we plant today must
provide shade for our
great-grandchildren whether they come
from the east or the west the south or
the north to give them all they need to
grow and breathe easily
a few years ago standing in this very
same spot I told you that Europe was the
love of my life I love Europe still and
shall do so forever thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
get out CAC Thank You president there's
not Claude during the course of your
speech you've offered us a range of
pointers you've set outs and prospects
in the coming debate we'll be able to
strengthen some of the positions I
believe that Parliament in the final
spirit of this voluntary term will be
able to confirm a number of the items
still in the pipeline as you've said we
cannot allow ourselves to be made
scapegoats have scapegoats we found
elsewhere but at the heart of democracy
so I would urge us to start by thinking
for example about the need for
Parliament to have the power of
legislative initiative we're the only
Parliament in the world which lacks that
power to take the legislative initiative
you quite rightly underscored and this
was welcomed by round of applause the
need for majority voting when we're
dealing with migration the Commission's
proposal and the parlance proposal on
the Dublin form could be a doctor by the
council by a majority vote but there's
always resistance if that reform were
passed we wouldn't have had the shot
account case in Italy so having welcome
to that proposal with massive applause
that we move to qualified voting I
assume there will be support for that
initiative and then all your initiatives
regarding Africa are of great interest
they're heading in the right direction
in line with Parliament's wishes we've
called for a fund for
perhaps Europe has finally woken up very
late in the day on the migration gender
we're listening if if we'd listened to
the appeals from a number of countries
and and a few years ago we might not be
where we are today significant
investment is required as you quite
rightly say we don't want a party where
we're just handing out gifts we need we
need developers economic diplomacy this
is a job that needs to be worked on
swiftly and Parliament will do its part
Parliament wants to play the role wood
will be taking the final vote our
representatives as you'll see in our
solutions are speaking out to defend the
rights of the three and a half million
new citizens living in the United
Kingdom and so economic union we need a
stronger commitment on our part because
any plaintiff Italy youth unemployment
has to be the main social issue we
address in the European Parliament's
president will be working intensively in
the remaining months to come up with
palpable responses for our citizens in
my capacity as president of Ponte I'll
use my best endeavours to ensure that
our institution is ever closer to our
citizens
the first speaker on behalf of the
European People's Party is manfred Weber
Europe is much more robust than four
years ago he overcame tough times I
think everybody can underline this but
without you sean plott without your
leadership it would have been impossible
to manage the last year's you coul had
the determination and us sincere heart
for Europe you defended the unity of
this continent and I want to thank you
for this and also I want to thank you
for the details of your love affair
which you shared with us in your
remarks Thank You Shawn close Janka but
there is still a lot to do and that is
the main message of today's State of the
Union speech we are in a working session
still we have to deliver and visit
today's announcements of jean-claude
Juncker and the Commission we can sum up
that all the proposals the Commission
promised at the beginning of their
mandate are now on the table of
Parliament and Commission and I would
also add these were not only the
proposals of the Commission at the
beginning they were the promises
promises of the EPP candidate
jean-claude Juncker in his election
campaign so to give a clear link between
what you promised in the campaign last
year and what you delivered in under
your leadership in the Commission and
also on the implementing part we have to
be aware that we delivered a lot
you mentioned already some of the
figures which are on the table on
economy stable growth rate all the
countries of the eurozone below 3% we
have created a lot of millions of new
jobs our companies did so Mario Draghi
gave now a clear signal that he will
stop and and finish the low interest
rate policy until the end of this year
so having this in mind it is a big
success story you have to practice it I
can remember jean-claude when we were in
your office after we got the messages
from from London about the outcome of
the referendum and we were disappointed
we were looking for answers and we were
a little bit scared about who'd other
probably follow will others probably
follow today Europe is united and ready
for a deal but London cannot give us a
clear answer so the EU is united and
London is in trouble
and finally on migration we reduced the
numbers of arrivals especially through
the Mediterranean route about more than
80% through 2015 so when you sum up all
these things some would probably say
this listing up all the success stories
is a boring exercise and probably shown
a list are not so much interested I
would say it's not the case I would say
it is a pre countries
pre-condition for the most important
thing a politician can have and that is
trust from the people we did it together
all the political families worked on
this I want to pick up only one aspect
because there is still a discussion
going on how we rescued the euro and yes
my party the EPP party is proud about
what we did it is about the policy of
Enda Kenny of pascha scaleo of Mariano
Rajoy of Samaras and of Anastasia Aires
in Cyprus they did the necessary steps
and we rescued Europe and the Europe we
see policy we invented and we
established and we created growth and a
good perspective for the future
perspective of the people and I cannot
remember let me say this on party
political terms I cannot remember that
Hollande ranchitos diploma or even
Moscow BC presented any kind of an
alternative proposal to how we should
answer the challenge which was on the
table dear colleagues even even even mr.
bull man even mr. Pohlman in the German
government is your contribution with
your party I didn't saw any alternative
proposal to present other tragedies to
overcome the crisis stable budgets and
and an ambitious reform programme are
necessary for a good economic future
that is what EPP beliefs
but now let's look to the future a
Europe of people is first of all a
Europe of security that's why we welcome
the proposal to present 10000 Frontex
officers to really contribute to a
strong border control security means
also still a fight against organised
crime and criminals their data exchange
is key for Europe and I also want to
underline that the Schengen area brings
more security and not less security and
that's why we asked the council to do
further steps to include Bulgaria and
Croatia inside of the Schengen area they
had waited for such a long time it's now
time to act and I asked the Romanian
government to stop the the risks about
the fight against corruption in Romania
because they are harming the
decision-making process towards
Bulgarian Croatia in the same way all
three countries must have the right to
join the Eurovision area immediately
I want to underline this again a second
point for a Europe of people is a Europe
of democracy and that's why I thank you
for the initiatives to make our European
elections safe not Russia nor China of
any external power we decide not drawls
not fake news not Cambridge analytics
will decide the people will decide the
Europeans will decide about the future
of this continent a third point for a
Europe of people is a Europe of fairness
I am considering what the truck driver
is thinking when he's listening to the
radio and they talk about the
self-driving trucks
I think he's asking himself what will
happen to me in such a world we are
standing in front of a revolution on the
labour market in such a world we have to
create a new fair deal for Europe and
that means and I think we share all in
this house the general ideas fair
taxation - contributions of the deep
digital business sector to the future of
this fair approach of a new social model
and today's Europe cannot be united
cannot be called united having in mind
that still the living conditions in the
European Union are not equal that's why
I think we
have to do more on common living
conditions and living standards in the
European Union and finally Europe of
people is a Europe which is strong on
global level you showed in the Oval
Office that we are strong economically a
child and we have to become also
politically a child and that's why to
change from the unanimous vote mechanism
to the majority vote system is fully
supported by the EPP let's stand up
let's make the century a European one
again crisis times are over now it's
time for a more united Europe for a more
democratic Europe and for a more
ambitious Europe thank you so much
very group order Alianza but on behalf
of social intelligence group woman has
the former president of the Commission
you started the mandate by promising
that you will be a politician a
political leader of the college and even
those who tend to criticize you on a
daily basis as I do of course only if
it's really necessary have to admit you
are a political leader of the European
Commission chapel you are not the pot
peril of the national capitals and you
are paying tribute to the decency of
this political grown in Europe by doing
so you are making a huge difference to
the predecessor of your own political
family which I appreciate but this is
not the issue at stake today the issue
is not whether you or whether the
college consists of dedicated Europeans
we are convinced of that otherwise we
would have not voted for you the very
question at stake is whether or not our
institution our policies are already fit
are already up to the task on which we
have to deliver in these days yes we are
in an era of huge crisis and whatever I
do not think that we already have
overcome crisis think of my creation you
mentioned it think on climate change
think of deepening divides between north
and south and east and west no we are in
transformational periods and to put it
in the words of Pope Francis at the
beginning of your mandate he said this
is not an era of change this is a change
of the era and the very question which
we discuss in our political group is why
can't we go more radical why can't we go
for a more clearer policy change to live
up to that migration
my Croatia you mentioned it and be fully
hearted support what you would say what
takes me wonder Manfred Weber was
reminding us on the fact that you were
the PPE candidate for the last
competition why is it that once you are
talking about migration you only have
the applause of the left side of this
house and all the others are silent I am
wondering why is that and I couldn't
understand because what he says is the
task of today yes we have to open legal
ways for migration it's a scandal we say
it's a scandal what we witnessed again
in this summer in the Mediterranean it's
disgusting to see people drowning even
that the official mission of the
European Union does not have any safe
harbors anymore because of the Italian
government the right-wing Italian
government and this is the mission of
the Commission's president who was the
EPP candidate for the last
decision-making for this mandate so
please take note of that when you are
going to prepare the summit in September
19th and discuss his proposals and come
to urgent action this is what we expect
from the council friends we will only be
able to put it in a broader picture if
we reach out to these societies of the
East yes they need a new compact they
have an interest by own private Slava
jean-claude Juncker by unproduced Lama
they have a dear interest in save energy
they have an interest in cohesion
long-lasting cohesion and in
reindustrialization of their countries
and they deserve it
the workers in the East countries
deserve a decent future and we have to
set up a new compact and I'm deeply
convinced that then it will be easier to
also solve the migration question let us
talk about the south it is not parable
that fifty percent forty fifty percent
of the young people in the south are
without any perspective we have to set
up a new master plan for the south why
not this could be done by the Commission
in the last a
months of this mended why not propose a
new master plan building on the
investment land of jean-claude juncker
extending that to the south and giving
back future and hope to the southern
countries and to make them again the
marketplaces of new ideas the bridge
builders to the cultures that are in our
neighborhood that would be a very
important task and we would encourage
you to do so but it's not only these
societies and the east and the South
that are falling apart look at the North
look at praxis we back of course the
position totally off of the Commission
and we stand united on that but look at
praxis look at the Swedish elections and
you see that ordinary people that
working-class people who have invested
their hope on Europe would like to see
us delivering on top of our agenda one
proposal why does the Commission not
come forward with the proposal that each
and every child in the Union in the
European Union has a child guarantee
deserves free health care deserves
proper education the first decent
housing that could be a proposal of the
next forthcoming months
to you a night the European Union for a
new future of the next generation this
is what we propose you are right we need
the defense of our institution we need
to fight against our enemies who would
like to undermine our democracy
cambridge analytic are all the enemies
from the outside as well as the enemies
from the inside and yes we need to
strengthen the community method for the
last months of your mandate good luck
Banco Vash
they're a group plow on behalf of the
European conservatives and reformists
mr. liquid Co has the floor
mr. mr. president it was a very
interesting speech I expect it would be
more over summing up speech and I was
just wondering what will we did
proportion between pluses and minuses of
course on the plus side I would put
young cotton which you mentioned I'll
pass on but I think which was has been a
success but there is also a minus side
in the first thing that comes to mind is
is a course in immigration and
demographic crisis of course you did not
do it directly
it was Chancellor Merkel who opened the
European borders but but you you could
have prevented her at least try to
prevent fair I don't know with what
effect but at least you could have now
we can of course subscribe to the idea
of strengthening European borders but I
think it's a somewhat belated proposal I
mean we could have talked about it some
time ago instead we spent a couple of
years on imposing the solution that was
absurd from the very beginning the
mandatory relocation and there was a lot
of energy spent of it a lot of bad blood
was shed and that typical sheriff of
bullying and invectives were thrown
around so but the real question is that
you should ask yourself and we all
should ask ourselves is the European
Union
in a better shape now than it was when
you took office and I think the answer
is clear no with all due respect
president Unger and all the successes
that you had know there has never been a
time in the history of European
integration in where Europe was more
disunited than it is now you talked
about unity no the unity is no longer
there it doesn't mean World War one or
World War two until recently integration
was one way street now it's two way
streets the number of people who are
dissatisfied deeply dissatisfied with
the European project is increasing
that's why our colleagues my colleagues
- are somewhat nervous before the
elections because they do not know what
will happen they're afraid of a possible
political earthquake and you cannot say
that the European Commission has no
share in it and no responsibility there
is at least political responsibility I
mean come on there is some relation
between cause and effect it's not the
fact that there are so many people who
have been antagonized made angry
irritated marginalist bullied rejected
the number is so high that you cannot
neglect it and you cannot decline any
responsibility for that you not as a
person but you as a chief of the
important European institution so I
would say that we have to somehow
rollback this process when you mentioned
that you wanted to
qualified majority votes in in more
areas of policy public life in Europe I
mean you are in for more trouble because
that will petrify this system in which
that some actors are equal and some are
more equal than others in which the
decision-making process is extremely
obscure nobody knows who makes the
decision and the division between north
and south east and west is still there
so if you want to have more trouble go
along the path and this will be
extremely interesting situation after
the election I mean to what extent you
will be responsive to the signals you
are a charming man president Juncker and
I love listening to you but when you
were talking today I thought my god we
are living in two different worlds I
wonder which one is the true they're a
group Adela Lanza on behalf of the
Alliance of liberals and Democrats for
Europe mr. Hofstra has the floor just
want to react to mr. Lugo it's
terrifying what do you say he's saying
here that we were never so disunited as
today as he has forgotten what Europe
was between the two world wars as he has
forgotten what Europe was in the Cold
War you have never heard about the wall
and the Berlin Wall and the Iron Curtain
Europe is united now it's not mr. de
hood though it's not mr. Lee hood ko mu
you have another vision
you say I'm of another world that
mystery of all very well for me no
problem it doesn't say things that are
completely crazy in a continent that
have seen 20 millions of death and
victims because of nationalism and
populism as you defended today that's
the point
I have to tell you I didn't want to
start to include with this but I find it
so terrifying that somebody gave us here
lessons about unity in Europe and then
trying with his government to do against
the rule of law against a number of
other things things that are against
European values sorry but I want to
applaud I'm sorry but I didn't want to
start I wanted to start with a plot the
state of the union of jean-claude
Juncker and especially a part that
nobody has talking about until now in
the interventions and is the part on
Africa jean-claude because you're right
I think we have done a clear proposal
they don't need charity what they need
is a true partnership between us and and
we and I think it's possible to create
what I call the biggest economic and
trade area in the world because if you
rob does that with Africa it will become
the ban is already the biggest trade
area and it will also in my opinion be a
true alternative for Africa for the
African citizens for the African people
to the takeover by the Chinese what is
happening every day every week in every
investment today in Africa so I think
that this Parliament has to support you
in this goal the question for me is a
little bit different than the question
of the other groups leaders the question
is last year you give us your legacy you
repeated it this year and the question
is can we put that into reality in the
coming years this legacy of you that's
the question it is existential year of
Elections with a number of tracks that
we honor standard the rise of
nationalist populist is everywhere in
Europe we have a number of authoritarian
leaders thank you to support me like mr.
Kaczynski like mr. Orban who in fact
hijacking or European parties I think
they do a little bit what Trump is doing
in the Republican Party
but let's be honest then your voice is
only an affirmation of this the
inconvenient truth is that all tried in
Europe is trying to undermine this
European Union and is in fact trying to
take over the European politics from
within and to do exactly the opposite
and the agenda that jean-claude Juncker
has presented us today and for that
reason I think and I think that
everybody of us certainly mum fret is
aware of this that in a few moments the
vote we're gonna have it's so important
that all pro Europeans all pro Europeans
are united against this alt-right
utterly Aryan tendency that we see in a
number of our countries because leaving
European Union because leading European
Union dear friends is not only a
question of mathematical strength it's
also a question of moral authority and
this moral authority is at stake for the
moment in European Union then in the
same spirit mr. Juncker I want to ask
you a specific thing for the Commission
that you mentioned very shortly that I
want to go more in detail I want to
answer the Commission in the coming
months will introduce a package of
proposals specific proposals and
specific measures to protect our
elections against the foreign meddling
that we have already seen in other
continents and in other places in Europe
identifying for example foreign agents
were active on the European social media
platforms as well as the extremist
politician with whom they are colluding
in the u.s. in the United States there
have been a special counsel appointed as
you all know Robert Mueller to
investigate in the Russian interference
in elections and they have already
launched a dozens of indictments that
there be handed down what I think we
need to catch up the fastest as possible
by also establishing our own special
prosecutor to investigate and to stop
all these information of
so in Europe and certainly before it is
too late in the light of the European
elections we will have next year and my
special request to you if the Commission
could take an initiative to this and to
bring it to the table of the council and
to the table of the European Parliament
and then finally my last point I want to
support you in one thing I think that
the most important point of your
intervention was the point that you have
made about the end of the use of bed at
the end of unanimity and the use of the
clothes the passerelle it's a French
word it was the most important proposal
and my proposal is don't load be
ambitious put all fields all articles of
the treaty that are possible in your
proposal of the close the passerelle
because I'm pretty sure that on the
other side of the table in the council
there will be a number of them who will
not be in agreement with you and it's
all based the best thing to ask the
maximum as possible in politics start
with 100% say I want the end of
unanimity inside the European Union
because is the main problem for the
moment to decide a number of things for
example the migration package mr.
president as you have mentioned where
the council is not even to decide even
when it is with a qualified majority so
my proposal is be ambitious put the
whole package in it all fields of
foreign policy all fit for me taxation
also put everything in it and we will
see what will be the endgame if we
support you you have said and that will
be my conclusion that this was in fact
the commission of the last chance you
remember that four years ago and I'm
always asking myself what can come after
the commission of the last chance in the
coming years so I think what will come
is something different the Commission
that we need in the future their
colleagues will be more than that it
will be a type of a new renewed European
government what we need
with one task that is to realize further
the legacy of Joe Conti ogre and also
the other visions that have been laid
down the latest months for example by
the French president in his Sorbonne
speech that will be the task of this new
commission and that is also the task we
will offer to the electorate as our
group as our movement as a real European
alternative on your legacy towards the
nationalists and the populist inside and
outside of this house thank you very
group now on behalf of the Greens if any
groups come against the floor thank you
president you yourself and many
colleagues have looked at the challenges
that we have globally and I totally
agree with them we have a lot of
challenges we have problems say the
least in our transatlantic partnership
we have China rising up there's so many
challenges out there but I would argue
that then that most more threatening
than anything that the world can throw
at us are actually the enemies from the
inside and then they are the obvious
ones the nationalists that bring hatred
division the racists that spread fear
and hate but there's also some less
obvious it's the decision makers that
actually don't take decisions that want
to keep the status quo who just want to
keep their own privileges and who are
just closing their eyes that's what's at
stake and then there is partisan
governments of which unfortunately we
have more and more who used the European
Union as a scapegoat for all their own
failures and that are cutting away for
tomorrow at democracy at civil liberties
bits by bits and piece by piece but a
Europe United a Europe that knows what
it stands for can face all external
problems and can be a front-runner in
the shining example in the world we can
be strong if we don't make ourselves
weak and Europe has promised to its
citizens to bring peace prosperity and
democracy
and those promises are still very
relevant but we need to renew them and
we need to bring them to fulfillment and
on peace we have major achievements to
show but we cannot rest on laurels and
Norwegian medals there are new global
challenges ahead that threaten our
future and that threaten our security
and the biggest one of them is climate
change we have seen it this summer that
climate change is happening it's
happening now
and it's happening everywhere from
disastrous harvests to forest fires
there's no way anyone could possibly
deny that and the good news about
climate change is that we know what to
do and the bad news about climate change
is that we don't do it but with Trump
leading the u.s. into space rather than
forward we cannot wait as Europeans for
someone else to protect our planet now
we have to do it ourselves and there's
no time to leave to lose and there the
Commission has been way too timid in the
past five years I have to say it is now
that we need to very quick change to
renewables and phasing out of the
climate killer coal and if climate
protection truly is a priority then it
should also be a priority in the multi
annual budget it should also be a
priority in the agricultural reform
Nagre cultures both a victim as well as
a culprit in climate change but farmers
can also be part of the solution
and here is where the Commission should
have been more ambitious with the
agricultural reform the European Union
has also always promised prosperity but
we are far away from the Triple A rating
that we should have I agree on social
policies and there's there austerity
imposed on member states in the past
without regards to consequences and also
without regards to whether this would
actually help anything that has
seriously undermined the European
promise of increasing living standards
but increasing the quality of life
that's not just a minor thing that you
can forget about it's an ass's in
essence of policymaking and we we need
to renew this promise and build a social
Europe and one not just of nice
declarations like we seen from
Guttenberg we need not just nice and
tensions that's all very nice but we
need a social Europe with real facts and
real figures we need common minimum
social standards in Europe all citizens
must get full access to social
protection to housing and traumatic
occur care a framework directive on
adequate minimum income schemes can
create such a safety net as volunteer
will be very interesting to see a
proposal by the Commission so that we
can ensure that safety net for everyone
and not just for lucky few and Europe
has promised democracy rule of law and
civil liberties to all its citizens and
that was a very strong call for all the
countries that wanted to join for all
the people living under dictatorships
who were being deprived from freedoms
like the country where I myself was born
and our continent has a long and bloody
history of oppressions of tanks rolling
against protesters of people suffering
in prison camps and it's only thanks to
those courageous people who were
marching for freedom who were marching
for democracy who did not give up that
today in the European Union we have that
democracy we have those civil liberties
and we have freedom but those very big
successes they are under threat we need
to fight for them again every single day
because inside Europe today
judges are being dismissed corruption is
being legalized newspapers are closed
universities arrest and civil society
treated as criminals and this is not a
detail this is a threat to all of us and
again today as well
courageous people are standing up
marching for human rights their own
rights and the rights of their neighbors
and they're marching for freedom but in
Sicily or Romania beaten cabinets or
beat in Piron and they defend democracy
they defend humanity and they defend
Europe and we see as well that if we
sign up together than we will really
have power then we are really strong
together and I think more of now than
ever it is now the task and
responsibility of all of us
to take a stance to take up all of our
responsibilities we have
responsibilities you as president of the
Commission we all as members of the
European Parliament but all Europeans
from north to south from east to west
because if Europe loses on democracy
then it will lose itself and this is
about more than about one country or
another country this is about the
achievements on this continent that so
many people have even died for this is
about our true self true self of Europe
and it is time to stake us to take a
stance thank you please we need to
respect the timing i no matter group of
a feather on behalf of the confederal
group of the European United Left Nordic
Green left mr. Zimmer has the floor
thank you very much president mr.
Juncker today I think you did a bit a
very intensive speech giving your
political position with which you have
exercised the Office of Commission
president I'd like to express my respect
for that I think it makes it easier for
us to speak about what from the point of
view of the various political groups in
the European Union Union what should be
different I'd like to start with the
evaluation of whether we are in a
position where we can say we've got over
the crisis we're in a position where we
are girded for all the challenges of the
future that we've prepared so that
people have the feeling of social
security of solidarity of a community in
the European Union I'm saying do you
know very clearly yesterday when the
Greek Prime Minister was here one
sentence
was very clear very demonstrative he
said we're out of the men out of
memorandum we've survived when he says
we've survived if that's the result of a
policy which has been shaped by the
Union and the Commission a sort of
crisis management which is on the the
backs of the poorest and has meant that
inequality has become deeper that we
don't have the the safety the security
that we can look to the future we all
have the feeling that in the upcoming
elections there's something facing us
where we can say today we have to
deflect it because because we don't have
we don't have a Europe of solidarity of
peace and the whole lot of issues where
we have to say today's policies it won't
work like that we have to see that ten
years after the start of the financial
crisis the level of prosperity of the
pre-crisis era has not been has not been
reached in many countries and people not
benefiting from growth there are rights
of workers in many countries have being
severely cut we must give a signal that
these rights and the protection of
employees and those who are not in any
job that we get them back that we
strengthen them that we accept that that
is part of it part of being the European
Union and we don't want that the
promised the social triple a becomes a
triple aid for a future military
strength of the European Union it can't
be that we're taking money from the
European budget for from for the fund
that you're talking about the heading
that you used showing strength and
showing strength to the outside and
protecting citizens
and reminds me of the Austrian
presidency they they're saying Europe
there protects and they're making very
clear it's not about a social Union is
not about that at all there's no
specific goal in the description of the
presidency it's about protecting the
external borders and turning away
refugees and this humanitarian
catastrophe that we've seen in the
summer is being continued I'm very
thankful that you said where the problem
lies
and who is blocking and I think that as
a parliament we must make it very clear
that we need Dublin that we shouldn't
accept that the council is constantly
blocking and and and they're simply
descending into inactivity the
commission of what what you expect when
the Commission say say this loud and
clear it well for active actives and for
activists and actors they don't know
where the cause is line who they can
turn to who they can fight with together
if we don't know who is responsible for
what what responsibilities are borne by
the individual institutions we must make
that very clear otherwise we can't win
over voters who can't get over this
lethargy when it comes to fighting for
Europe we must tackle that together
there must be a mission and then we'll
differentiate ourselves in the left from
all right wing attempt to destroy Europe
I wanted to stress that probably better
than on behalf of the group the aftd mr.
farlow what a picture you paint a
european union of peace of prosperity of
contentedness and as you said you're
trying to make it a little more perfect
every day well it's a very good
advertising slogan but any what
surprised me since your last State of
the Union speech there's been a seismic
clinic
in Europe perhaps one even on a par with
brexit Italy a founding member of the
Union the third biggest economy in the
eurozone now has a coalition government
between the five stars of malaga that is
polling over 60% of the vote and is
posing a direct challenge both in terms
of the management of the eurozone and
indeed how the migration crisis is
handled
you made no acknowledgement of that at
all no acknowledgement but the populist
revolt that is sweeping through
virtually every single Member State
instead you'll to carry on regardless
and I noted your continued use of the
phrase sovereign Europe what you're
talking about is a deeper centralization
of power a centralization of power in
terms of Europe's foreign policy a
centralization of power as you first
laid out last year in terms of building
a European army more power at the center
for taxation all of this of course
meaning less to be done at the
nation-state level and now another
10,000 European border guards paving the
way for a federal border police in
Europe when I tell you something if
you've got problems with the Italians
now you ain't seen nothing yet
when you put that proposal to them but
it's all about centralization power
power power but here's the funny thing
you appealed to our sense of European
patriotism so why is it the patriotism
of the nation state level is considered
to be insolent bad nasty xenophobic
probably racist into the bargain and yet
and yet patriotism at a European level
is a good and a virtuous thing and I'm
afraid this idea of European patriotism
this idea of putting that flag above
their own nation state flag is for the
birds
people do not have a profound sense of
European identity they have a sense of
national identity and and in a way that
is the great dividing line between your
vision of Europe and that increasingly
that has been said by the electors we
wish to live in nation
States now on brexit mr. Janka on the
Irish border already there are huge
differences between the north and the
south differences of politics of tax of
currency and of law and we managed and
if we can get to a free trade deal
well of course there'll be no
difficulties whatsoever and I thought
you had some very positive things to say
you said our vote to leave was a vote to
leave the single market and its
associated parts I agree with you quite
why mrs. may at checkers wants to opt
back into much of it I don't know but
you said twice that we need to come to a
free trade deal
it's what European exporters won and it
is absolutely and it's what we want
surely now the time is right the ground
is prepared for a Canada plus style
trade deal between you and between us we
leave political union but we carry on
doing business on a tariff-free basis we
want it increasingly I think that you
want it
let's get brexit sorted and mr. behalf
stat you'll be happy you'll see the back
of us
they're a group for Europe I didn't on
behalf of the European nations and
Freedoms group mr. BAE has the whole
mysterious after your Commission came
into office and necessary before the
European elections we have to take stock
and clearly you are in the Commission a
condensed form of everything that the
people of Europe can no longer stand
your Commission's action is opaque
anti-democratic and clear it's a big
when you decide by executive Fiat to a
point mr. Zell Meyer as Secretary of the
Commission you mr. Juncker flaunted all
the rules
it's against democracy when Commissioner
hitting an inane extremely extraordinary
arrogant statement said that the
financial market would teach the
Italians the proper way to vote and it's
also against democracy when just now you
stated that the EU budget would be
pinned down up to 2027 without waiting
to see what are say in the elections may
next year and you've been punitive
towards Poland and Hungary we saw a fun
example of a Stalin desk show trial just
yesterday
just because they've been brave enough
to stand up for the values of our
civilization and they refuse the
compulsory quotas of migrants that
you've wanted to impose on them you've
also been punitive towards the British
you want to make them pay the price of
their freedom by refusing any sort of
trade agreement with them well we have
countries who are not in the EU such as
Norway in Iceland to have access to the
single market and you're increasing this
welter of trade rooms around the world
you could refuse that to the British and
of course the work of your commission
has been characterized by the way you
sped up the dismantlement of any kind of
economic protection
you've been encouraging unfair
competition within Europe
with the posting of workers and with the
wide world with free trade agreements
with a severe impact on the environment
undermining our industry our farming
industry it applies to Sita and the
future agreements with Athenian and off
you went to to Tokyo today without the
opinion or let alone any input from the
European pound all the national
parliaments to sign up to a prior
agreement on free trade with Japan and I
say of course your Commission has been
characterized by it's crazy migration
policy our colleague mr. liquid go just
now underscored the point very
moderately yet nonetheless he found mr.
Haas nuts and strike him down with a
thunderbolt attacking top lists but
within this chamber he is the picture of
hatred of any differently from his own
and we've just seen another
demonstration of that your Commissioner
from applause talked about migration and
saying that you were going towards
accepting migrants as something that's
vital for our continent so economic
future and you've talked about
increasing alykum migration even more
that is undoubtedly your greatest
particularly you've made it possible for
people to organize this mass immigration
which is weakening our continent and
leading the suffering of our peoples the
president's the next speaker is mr. Hyde
of ski an unattached member jovanni
Chauncey college Anki college if mr.
president ladies and gentlemen I want to
start by thanking president young care
for his speech I appreciate your
pragmatism your principle of that it is
better to be in efficient and effective
in small matters and careful in a big
matters contrary to the Socialists who
demand financing
revenue and jobs from the a European
level
so I appreciate a you
pragmatism but what I missed in your
speech is supporting our free market I
missed in your speech calls for doing
away with protectionism in Europe and
supporting of a small and medium-sized
enterprises contrary to mr. Ferrara who
took the floor maybe three minutes
before me I would be in favor of a
Europe taking a more responsibility for
our defense policy I have been watching
this process with a great interest I
think Europe should share with the u.s.
the responsibility for our defense but
this needs practical practical
solidarity European a must feel that
Europe will defend Eastern Europe with
the same vigor that with which it
defends southern Europe and the Europe
would not tolerate counterproductive
initiative like no Stream - thank you a
senior presenter Rocco missional a
president of the Commission during the
course of your speech you reminded us of
the role of journalists as people who
uphold the state of law once again I
would like to remind the house that the
murderers of two journalists have Daphne
coruña Galicia who was murdered in Malta
and in kucik murdered in soraka had
still not been found until such time as
we establish who hired them we will
continue to speak out against the course
of events president Juncker has the
floor
president ladies and gentlemen
I'll make some remarks very briefly and
address some specific points that have
been put to me mr. Bulman first of all
who drew our attention on the need to
develop the rights of children and
social rights more generally I'd like to
point out that the Commission has
proposed within the the gothenburg
process an action of that type action
chapter 3 number 11
I'd like to say to mrs. Keller that
today and yesterday I pleaded that the
Gothenburg declaration shouldn't should
be implemented it into and become action
and including legislative action to mr.
hofstadt the Commission is proposing a
text on the protection of European
candidates for the European elections
all that's well advanced to mr. farrar
there you have to listen before you
speak I did not put national patriotism
and European Patrick ISM on the same
footing I said that one doesn't exclude
the other I will continue to be a
patriot but an enlightened Patriot not
was a small Grand Ducal Patriot I like
my country but I don't detest the others
and if you say
in a different world it's not mr. Faraj
who said it but a previous speaker yes I
don't want to live in this world made of
hatred I don't want to live in that
world
I'd like to make it mine and yours thank
you get out sit I've had all I know
there they concede thank you no Council
mr. president Luka president Ayane
honorable members ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of the council let me first of
all thank president Juncker for his
address and for his analyzes regarding
the challenges but also the
opportunities facing our union at this
crucial juncture as we approach the end
of the legislature I won't be able to go
into all the detailed elements of
president Juncker speech and his
considerations deserve a careful
examination obviously he touched upon
issues that are at the center of our
attention but let me turn to something
else at the outset I would like to
stress that a fully secant what
president young has stated at the
beginning of his speech our union is a
union of peace it is a union of
prosperity and we should show respect
towards this union deal with it
carefully and protect our common values
now let me turn to some issues touched
for instance the idea of further
strengthening frontex
it is an important element of a
functioning EU policy on migration it
was already discussed at the European
Council in June and it will be a main
topic for the discussions at the
informal heads of state or government
summit in Salzburg and yes the
strengthening of frontex is in our view
a prequel
addition to establish eros island and
well-based
asylum European Asylum system we hope to
find as much as possible a common ground
and to bring things forward the European
Council in June also reconfirmed the
necessity of bringing our cooperation
with Africa to a new level a visible
expression of the same will be a
high-level forum which we are currently
planning to hold in Vienna at the
beginning of December and as far as the
proposal on summer time is concerned we
are planning to put it on very quickly
on the agenda of the council given the
specific political context before the
end of the current legislative term
there is indeed a need to concentrate on
the delivery of pending proposals and on
the effective implementation of
legislation be assured that the Austrian
presidencies energy and determination is
fully focused on this in recent months
there have been developments which may
on surface seem contradictory there is
much talk about Europe's accept
assessment concerns in this respect
ahead of next year's election of the
European Parliament yet at the same time
we have seen positive signs on renewed
trust and higher levels of support for
the Union for our part as presidency we
are confident that there is enough unity
and determination in Europe to tackle
this challenges ahead and to transfer
them into opportunities our motto is a
Europe that protects and this is what we
try to contribute I think this motto
could also apply to a series of elements
of president Joko speech today Europe
has emerged strong in many ways from the
crisis we have faced in recent years but
now we need to act swiftly and
determinately on the economy on
migration on security and on digital
Europe especially cybercrime the
increasing number of cyberattacks
two crucial questions on cybersecurity
must be discussed digitally we will
strive to use the efforts of
digitalization on the one hand at its
best and on the other hand we have to
deal carefully with the possible
negative effects the goal must be a
secure stable secure single digital
market and the highest trust of his
consumers of this civil service of
Europe ladies and gentlemen addressing
you in this hemicycle in July
Chancellor quids presented to you the
priorities of our presidency namely
security and the fight against illegal
migration securing prosperity and
competitiveness through digitalization
and stability in the European
neighbourhood I will not go through
these principles and priorities again
they focus on achieving tangible results
through demonstrating to European
citizens we use indispensible added
value for its citizens and member states
and of course this is particularly
important in this period as we near the
end of the legislature as president you
mentioned we have a lot of work to do in
the coming months in terms of
legislation but there are of course also
the informal meetings of the head of
state or government in Salzburg
next week and the European Council
meetings in October and in December in
which crucial decisions will have to be
made and beyond our presidency the
European election of course and informal
meeting in Sibiu in May 2000 and 19 when
the implementation of the leaders agenda
will be reviewed and the strategic
agenda for the period 2019 to 2024 will
be prepared
ladies and gentlemen finally speaking of
delivering on priority policies I would
also note that today's debate on the
State of the Union is a key moment in a
new annual cycle of programming now the
General Affairs Council edits meeting on
18 September will have an
exchange of views on the basis of the
Commission's letter of intent which was
issued only yesterday we also look
forward to continuing the fruitful
dialogue among the three institutions on
priorities particularly on
implementation of the joint declaration
on the youth legislative priorities for
2018 and 2019 delivering results can be
achieved in a focused and targeted way
through our joint programming let me
reaffirm the councils commitment to this
process and assure you that the
presidency will continue to be a
determined partner thank you for your
attention thank you state secretary edge
Stadler we now move to our speakers list
the first to speak is mr. Kaspari
one and a half minutes circuit
Commission's presidency
mr. president of the Commission dear
colleagues president Jonker put it
nicely the European Union today
politically economically and socially is
doing a lot better than people think
that said and there are still a lot of
challenges ahead many people are
concerned or are unhappy and often these
concerns and this unhappiness stems from
the fact that people have expectations
of the EU which we can't meet they have
expectations which member states don't
equip us to meet and the European Union
doesn't have a sufficient competence to
deal with it either
now we need to deal with tax breaks for
companies such as Apple and Amazon we
need a stronger foreign policy we want
to protect our external borders and deal
with migration but if we want to tackle
all of those issues then we find that
Member States have not devolved
competence for they said to us and that
we therefore can't deal with these
issues we would learn full support to
the
being commissioned and representative of
council i hope that the council takes up
these proposals made by mr. younger so
that these issues are discussed in
council and so that finally the european
union will be in a position to meet the
expectations of its citizens so that
they are content with the EU and so that
this project can be successful and work
to the benefit of our citizens thank you
thank you two and a half minutes madam
Rodriques president of the peasant of
the Commission is just presented to us
an agenda geared towards the future the
agenda of a true European politician it
is indeed the case that the time for
European sovereignty has arrived in
response to climate change
utilization and trade there's a need to
find a different way of governing
migratory flows why are we not making
progress with this agenda the reason for
that is that we face forces from the
past who are arguing that it's better to
protect our citizens just behind
national borders that's completely
illusory because today it's not possible
to protect your citizens solely on the
basis of national policies you need
europe-wide solutions the real reason
why we're not making headway with this
agenda is that we face the forces
protecting the status quo conservative
forces who resist the enforcement of
these europe-wide solutions for them the
issue of migration merely requires a
well-organized European border but
progressive forces have to make the case
that that's not enough you need a real
partnership with Africa you need a
european-wide response when it comes to
hosting refugees and protecting them
that is a feeling that it's the most
concerti forces that it's as if the
economy is recovering but progressive
wasn't it feel that we need much more do
they have to have the energy shift and
push the economy in the right direction
but there's a great blockage here mr.
Weber has had to sign to the composition
but it's just not possible the eurozone
will continue to be characterized by
divergences and so we have a proper gun
budget policy conservative forces think
it's enough to have jobs it's not enough
the quality of jobs has to be regarded
as a true social pillar with a contract
which will provide proper protection for
all European citizens this can only be
achieved when progressive forces manage
to overcome those defending the status
quo who have been posing obstacles in
the course of two European solutions
thank you one minute mr. Solow
presidenta mr. Juncker has invited us
about the need to defend European values
against chauvinist nationalism and I
couldn't agree more but I like to make
him a suggestion please go to Catalonia
and visit our nine political prisoners
amongst them to former Emme peace please
go and have a chat with them about the
core values and founding principles of
the European Union and after having
discussed with them ask yourself what
are these people this democratic
peaceful and pre the peon people doing
in jail as yourself if having
politicians and civil society leaders in
jail for nearly a year without trial on
the basis of fake accusations just for
having organized a referendum just for
having implemented a democratic mandate
if all this is according to European
values yesterday over a million people
in Barcelona
claiming for our democratic rights
standing up for European values against
repression and people convinced despite
feeling let down by European
institutions that Europe needs to be
part of the solution
Thank You mr. Omar Jay one minute please
merci thank you I don't want to be
unjust with you a lot has to do with
your actions you're the rich are
thanking you because your commission
will have been a chance for tax evasion
a chance for the lobbies and for bio and
Monsanto which can continue to poison
people for years it's an opportunity for
what the what has happened to Greece and
for all those who are bearing down on
the common group grew a good president
macron will - thank you - for your
encouragement for putting in place a
structural reforms opening up to
competition in railways reform of
pensions and dismantling workers rights
president Janka vice president
timmermans I have - I regret to say that
if the rich say thank thank you the
people of Europe won't be thanking you
thank you one minute mr. Morten
president envious paranoid to Buddy
Largo Madam President we're talking
about the State of the Union today and
president young has given us his vision
of that and he took a historical
approach but his analysis is wrong in
its most basic points for example he
said that the crisis had been overcome
that's not true it's just been swept
under the carpet and the day will come
that we will have to pay the
consequences of that
peace is also not as important as it was
in the 20th century and we have a
migration policy which isn't working and
which is being supported by this house
and that's a problem to then ever closer
Union as a policy really is outdated
as member states are leaving and
obviously they haven't understood the
warnings of Bridget this commission and
this policy is now nearing its end and
that was clear from your speech to
Mister Yunker if the EU is to be strong
it really should concentrate on a number
a small number of core tasks and should
leave sovereignty to member states
unfortunately with the events yesterday
with the presence of mr. Albin the
opposite is happening - on topic thank
you very much madam president
it's very amusing how the first row is
praising each other you're not used to
opposition that have no fear you don't
fear each other we all love Europe
there's no doubt about that but what
have you heard today we haven't heard
much from jean-claude Juncker he used
the word solidarity six times that
colleagues solidarity isn't a one-way
street
but we saw that yesterday in the debate
with on Hungary a left-wing the
left-wing stressed that spot has become
at the white paper in March 2017 we
haven't heard anything about that I
can't go down a route where I don't know
what direction I'm going in it's very
strange
Janka knows that this migration crisis
will change Europe sustainably and we're
just in the first stage and it's very
late in he's very late in coming with
his proposals and and after a delay of
one year the Korea crisis hasn't got any
better
madam Todd's one minute thank you madam
president
today mr. Jonker wanted to establish his
legacy but sadly that legacy will be the
loss of a member state and more
importantly the loss of confidence in
the European Union as demonstrated by
recent elections in Sweden Italy and
Germany as well as a migration crisis
that continues to cost lives on brexit
mr. Jonker reaffirms his view that there
should be no hard border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic of
Ireland
I agree but he also reaffirms support
for the Belfast agreement however the EU
backstop proposal ignores one of the
core principles of that agreement the
principle of consent let me make it
clear once again in this house there can
be no borders and certainly not those
imposed by the European Union within the
internal market of the United Kingdom or
interference in its constitutional
framework Great Britain is Northern
Ireland's largest marketplace where we
sell more in the Republic than in the
Republic of Ireland the rest of Europe
and the rest of the world put together
equally 70% of everything that comes in
to Northern Ireland for consumers or the
manufacturing process comes from GB
customs or regulatory barriers I'm
really good families thank you could I
just say if I give everyone that leeway
I'm in trouble and you will be annoyed
with me because votes will run late so
please be strict on your time for one
and a half minutes now mr. levin dosti
queer young queer yuckiest
state of a union thank you very much
well what the state of the union is we
shall find out during the election in
May of 2019 people our electorate will
tell us that by participating in the
election or abstaining from it the EU
is not really about institutions that is
about what binds us why we want to be
together the EU is about feeling we
stand to gain together and not to lose
and I think we still have nine months to
make the verdict of our sovereign to be
a voice over trust and I hope the
results of the election it will be
conformed to the optimistic speech of
mr. Juncker and on behalf of the Polish
delegation in EPP I want to thank mr.
Juncker for the service in favour of
Europe we know what to do not adopt
regulations which make people's lives
are more difficult for some multi-annual
EU budget is important not for all
because some prefer is law European
budgets but for most I think financial
predictability is important that whether
people trust us or not all this boils
down to security safety and security
this is important thank you thank you
one minute madam Van Brunt thank you as
you know you never get a second chance
to make a first impression and in that
sense you will never get a second chance
to be the commission of the last chance
and that's what you promised us when you
started this legislature and that ship
has sailed I have to say we know now
that the successor of mr. Juncker he
will be then the next Commission
president of the last chance and this
time it might get really serious
yesterday we saw the face of the anti
Democrats and we all know that sort of
extremism in Europe is based on raising
inequalities and the fact that our
citizens they they fear the future for
themselves and their children
this Commission promised us a triple-a
on social issues what we have is a park
full of a lot of paper and nice words
but not too concrete measures
to fight the inequalities and you said
you would tackle migration and make sure
that we have good answers to that and
now everything is based on the fact that
we need to defend our borders and last
but not least you said we would wreck we
would be top for the climate change we
did some things in in in a good
direction but we lack the real ambition
to behave a sustainable future thank you
very much madam mr. shadow one minute
mr. president you present you wherever
you are you ended up listening cos you
mentioned the dramatic consequences of
climate change with us but on the July
when you met to Donald Trump you
committed the European Union to
importing more GMO soil full of run-up
and shale gas you have no mandate for
this diplomat you didn't hear the
undesired in the part of Europeans to
shrug off glyphosate Pacific and your
commission has contributed to failing to
impose anti-dumping duties on Chinese
solar panels leaving unjustly open to
them
gracious appetite your your deals with
Mercosur and all the others mean a
market of animals suffering
deforestation bad food climate change so
it's our responsibility to listen to the
citizens of Europe and to depend on the
wind and the the Sun not on Putin and
Trump luckily a private key reunion
thank you madam chair mr. younger from
yesterday's discussion on Greece
it's
shows and Europeans all of a sudden
remember that there is no sovereignty in
Europe we all of a sudden remembered
that the peoples of the south paid and
bore the brunt of the crisis that the
priority in Europe is said the interests
of banks and multinationals and not the
working people and the youth this is
where we are at right now in the
European Union this is the nature of the
European Union from the address of mr.
Juncker now we understand that the
future of Europe will be an
intensification of austerity measures
and reforms a further dissolution of
social rights unemployment poverty which
is a perfect ground for a nationalism to
prevail but European nations will only
be able to prosper outside of the
European construction with a true
ability of solidarity and prosperity
thank you thank you one minute mr. chuka
president the UK president young it's
game over it's over with you telling
fables about your vision for Europe
there used to be a Europe that was going
to make sure that families were becoming
richer and safer but that is now failed
it's a doomed enterprise for families
citizens and businesses alike and this
European project has now led to the fact
that they're poorer and less safe now
mr. president said that Europe's
people's need certainty but you don't
know what Europe's population needs
unfortunately the only certainty that
the citizens of Europe have is that they
don't like what you have to say I think
you need to
self-assess your own policies and this
through the eyes of European citizens
they want you to step down
please stop thinking that the Italians
are there to be made fun of and please
stop telling lies to wonder half minutes
mr. Prost
mr. president you looking at this stock
taking your mandate but that is not all
the global context is more difficult and
there isn't a lot of friendship and
solidarity around and you know that with
when it comes to trade with us the
question asked by many members what is
your doing
what is the Commission doing what are
you doing mr. Juncker I would prefer to
us put the questionnaire differently
what's the Member States doing a year
ago on the in the State of the Union you
talked about the European institutions
and you talked about reciprocity and
this was legitimized by your what you
said about Europe which protects and
what about the expectations of companies
and citizens what are the Member States
when do when when it comes to migration
and what are you doing when then no
longer speak and migrate migrations
policy based on the arrival of ships
isn't serious what people expect is that
they get their told the truth states
can't find a solution sometimes when
they're given the means to do it the
failure of Europe
it's the failure of dialogue between
states have you said just now the
Europeans sovereignty exists thanks to
the sovereignty of member states it
doesn't replace countries or member
states Thank You mr. Andrzej let's show
you a member sees a temple mr. Gingka
everybody maybe we need something more
important than
changing the cloth what you did on
glyphosate will be what people remember
from your conservative term in office
you're leaving your defensive screens
the rest of the world we you promised an
ambitious Commission the push of the
last chance but holding the UN s DG's
and a social and environmental economy
you said but in fact your Commission has
sacrificed our farmers on the altar of
free trade you made a mockery of ecology
between men and women and in peril the
health of millions of Europeans not
blinded the precaution principle on
website on endocrine disruptors or GMOs
and the multi-annual financial framework
has no vision or ambition that's not
going to change the balance what are you
waiting for
you're like oh like you mr. Anker thank
you for joining that parallel between
European begged ISM and enlightened
Bechet and that's why I would ask you in
your program to include the reform of
the European Arrest Warrant the world
has changed a lot over the last 15 years
for example it doesn't protect us
against cyber terrorism or terrorist
propaganda online which which you
mentioned and the manipulation of
election results which you also touched
on personal data not protected by the
virus won't endure nor again attempted
cooze my country Spain suffered an
attempted coup a year ago the Spanish
supreme court does not have available to
it
all those were responsible so that they
could be brought to because they the
peasant interjects thank you I only have
one minute and a half
okay so it's one minute and a half with
a limit of words thank you I will
continue my pace Espania my country
Spain suffered an attempted coup a year
ago but the Spanish Supreme Court does
not have all those behind it before it's
because a court in another country has
denied it that possibility in Spain is
not the only instance in which the
European restaurant does not be working
the Spanish Constitution cannot be
protected without mutual confidence if
the euro the European restaurant doesn't
what properly was to become of Schengen
it doesn't make sense for showing to be
used for certain countries to close
their borders to refugees while other
countries open their borders to
criminals this is no time for squabbling
and judging one one another or attacking
one another if we want a European Union
which is truly United then it has to be
a European Union of justice thank you
thank you thank you very much president
in the EU borders seem to only be open
for capital they're being closed for
people xenophobic attacks are no longer
considered as half-witted babbling their
part and parcel of argumentative
strategy the space for criticizing
xenophobia and his discourse is
shrinking and the pressure to accept
such rhetoric as common practice is
mounting populist leaders are spreading
the fear of an imaginary group of people
the refugee crisis is being abused to
cover up a crisis of the European
institutions the main mistake lies in
the inadequate common Asylum policy
which should be based on solidarity
before the elections next year the EU is
faced with a choice either it will
choose radical xenophobia or radical
social changes if it is to survive those
of us who believe in its achievements
have to fight for the
respect of European values the other
road leads to closing in national states
Thank You mr. Ron Schara one and a half
minutes
Sheila proceed the end president was
president of the Commission first of all
I would like to pay homage here to mr.
Juncker as a to European he in fact
isn't an example to all of us in that
regard I'm going to raise a point where
I was rather disappointed with the
vision he set before us namely the
forthcoming multi-annual financial
framework the Commission has come
forward with the proposal which
increases divergences it's a poor
proposal for the cohesion countries how
can you explain a 24% for Spain and 5%
for Finland
how can it be that that great shirt is
losing's explain to me please getting
some more if you argue that certain
countries have have had growth that
that's at anything I mean so they're
trying to make up the the gap and
they're being punished by European funds
even though they reach level which is
far below the average and that's not the
way forward for the next seven years
this is no discourse for the future so
we need thoroughly to revisit the MFF
I'm concerned to team Portugal having
this attitude as as previous speakers
had we've been going but from a low
basis we need to be condemned Russia's
policy lastly respect for the Solidarity
fund applied in the instance of wealth
has in Portugal more than half of the
funds was used for red tape rather than
addressing the situation on the ground
that's deplorable and the Commission
should speak out about that the money in
this article is for the victims and the
regions affected not for the the
Portuguese state apparatus
the Chevron shell there is a blue card
request from Adam Rodriguez do you
accept Adam 30 seconds please mr.
honchell something you couldn't resist
turning a European debate into a
national debate but on your point I
don't think you're in any position to
say what you've just said you represent
a government which worsens the the
quality and quantity position of
Portugal whereas the sessions going to
be doing the exact opposite so I think
you should withdraw your comments before
you start it is a question usually on
the debate it was more a point but you
had 30 seconds to respond
I would just say this I was talking
about not on your financial framework I
know that for mr. Rodriguez it's of no
interest to see the Portuguese couldn't
make him poor use of it but I mentioned
it Italy in Finland and the other
countries on and I would say that the
Bobson employment was thanks to the
Socrates government of your party
thankfully in in the video on Greece
there was acknowledgment that pass was
well used government did a lot of good
for Portugal they the president into
James one minute please
mr. khufu thank you thank you madam
president as a co reporter of the
financial crimes and tax committee I was
pleased to hear you talk about the need
for combating money laundering what we
see in Europe is a crisis and we need a
real comprehensive reform of anti-money
laundering systems regulations and
authorities it's not only a crisis it's
not only money laundering it's a tax
evasion and tax avoidance crisis - its
corruption its terrorist finance it's
already too rich and too powerful
sweetling the tax covers of our
countries and this must be stopped now
for some in Europe for some of Europe's
largest banks the free movement of
capital has become freedom from
responsibility it is because these banks
are so-called well too big to fail
let me tell the Commission this bank had
already failed they have failed their
responsibility to society and we need to
hold them accountable in the danske bank
case alone transactions worth more than
the entire state budget of Denmark is
now under suspicion of money-laundering
so pretend younger and Commission we
need not only to talk tough on holding
banks accountable we need to be tough on
the banks thank you so much thank you
mr. Neidermeyer one minute thank you
very much I know one minute and not too
many words jobs and girls this was the
key slogan of European Commission few
years ago and I wonder if all of us
still remember that word has changed
and sometimes it's changed actually to
better also despite of unfortunate
decision of people of United Kingdom
position of European Union in the world
has strands in significantly and now
European Union represents hopes and
wishes of hundreds of million people
around the world but successive of
successes of past belongs to past what
counts is the future and the way how we
were tackled the challenges and the
problems of today they decide about the
future of our union on earth of our
continent and the list of these problems
is demanding migration security economic
problems foreign policy tax issues
environment are among those on the list
but we shouldn't forget and this is what
mr. Rinker has said the unity
cooperation and solidarity is what we
are decided because it succeed and we
shouldn't forget it thank you thank you
one minute madam Brussels grazie
Presidente thank you president vice
president
please could you remind president
Younker that er we very much appreciated
his call for a sovereign Europe but also
for a Europe in which the Euro functions
in a full manner and above all the
strength with which he proposed the
application of the passerelle clause we
would have appreciated a response from
the council on that let me also however
recall that - the economic crisis which
has been the scourge of our continent
during recent years which has increased
the gap between rich and poor needs to
be dealt with and we need to work for a
fairer Europe that should be our main
task we need to fight the sense of
solitude in which many Europeans live we
need to boost a feeling of community we
need to come up with measures for
European children we need to deal with
unemployment and we need to deal with
the salary gap between men and women the
European social pillar needs to be at
the heart of the European pillars of the
future and it's only in that way that we
can deal with people such as Albin and
others thank you mr. Karos president
members of the house what a difference
if we compare the discussion on the rule
of law and basic rights with jean-claude
yonkers today one divides Europe the
other makes the idea of Europe into a
political program and responds to the
challenges that we face in Europe and in
the world and brings Europe together so
thank you to you jean-claude juncker
we can also see the barriers the
attitudes and the ignorance that has to
be overcome in order to put the younger
plan into action let's begin with the
votes lunchtime European democracy is
more than the sum of its National
Democratic parts we have to refuse
authoritarians and ground our democracy
we need to make the Europe into a
political force capable of action I
agree with the analysis that says that
goals need to be achieved
let's move obstacles from the
legislative path let's accelerate
legislative procedure so that before the
elections we can meet the concerns and
make steps forward
let's make if you have political will
you can achieve an awful lot mr. Karos
there's a blue card request from madam
rapini will you accept the question
madam group any you accept yes Montanez
moved on appreciate inter don't you like
Cara Thank You president mr. Karos you
talked about the Jonker speech in
positive terms mr. Yonker said that he
wanted a Europe of peace and prosperity
now I understand your view but can we
really have peace and prosperity without
cohesion do you agree with the cuts to
the cohesion funds that the
commissioners proposed for the next
financial period
how can one achieve priority and
understanding for the people on the
single market without that I live in a
minute you can't answer all of the
questions that one might put but the
fact is that values the rule of law and
meeting goals is something that will
guarantee more peace and prosperity and
stability than other
the budget negotiations will be tough
because the challenge is the EU face
require more money more salad arity than
the budget currently has available to it
the describe the differences between the
Commission Council and the Parliament
positions is large but everyone has to
take a leap forward so that the younger
program can be put into action no for
one minute I give the floor to mr. Biden
hold sir thank you SHINee's paid in
young president thank you very much this
is really addressed to President Juncker
this morning very good speech
forward-looking for the good intentions
as so often in the past but we've got to
look at what is implemented 2015 you
talked about efficient border
supervision systems three years later we
find that we have not made much progress
in that direction and the reallocation
of refugees has been a very fraught and
difficult process and we hear
information that the our efforts in that
area is chronically underfunded schools
have had to be closed proposals have
been put forward which we are very happy
to discuss and debate but let's not
forget we've got to do our homework and
make sure that there is funding for the
requisite capabilities in the
surrounding area otherwise we'll see a
repetition of what happened in 2015
thank you thank you one minute madam to
land a bigger part de'longhi
would work yeah fantastic
Excel the artifact thank you very much
another present the language exactly
haven't said I'm going to be speaking in
Dutch because I know that the president
of the Commission understands Dutch and
it's really a personal appeal it for
four years in the Union State of the
Union debate I've been saying what my
criticisms were and the Commission and
the president of the Commission today
must be thanked for what they've done
he has worked from his heart and all the
way down to his toes pleading for
European solutions and that in difficult
times look at migration all of Europe
talks about better protection for our
external frontier the Commission comes
along with a proposal 10,000 border
cards and better more efficient
deportation and return policies and then
listen to the response what's going to
cost who's going to pay for that is this
not and this is not taking away Paris
from member states who is blamed if
nothing is done the European Union and
indeed the Commission first and foremost
the State of the Union is a debate and
it's a call for a sense of
responsibility and for leadership and I
hope that's what we get this time round
and thank you Commission for having
given us this basis thank you thank you
gracias president that thank you
president I'd like to thank mr. Yunker
for the self-criticism he used in his
speech he recognized the problems that
the European project is suffering during
this time there's been a lack of courage
there's been a lack of leadership to
steer in terms of steering the European
ship on the right path but in spite of
populist and the extreme right Europe is
more alive than ever and it is more
necessary than ever to face up to the
challenges that we have we need a strong
Europe that takes on common positions
and shows solidarity to deal with the
challenge of migration and to restore
dignity to our project we need a Europe
that can translate economic
into social justice and redistribution
we need strong welfare states we need a
European Union that can fight climate
change we need a european union with a
woman's face that does away with
gender-based violence and ensures more
equality in society we need a Europe
that restores our pride in belonging to
a space of community and respect as
strong Europe brings us all together
thank you thank you mr. Kelly Thank You
president and thank you president
Juncker
you referred to the Jonker plan which is
so successful in helping us get over the
economic recovery that they no longer
call it the include plan and as they
each were prepared for its successor
investing you I hope that can be equally
successful I think you also deserve
great credit for negotiating with the
wayward Donald Trump helping to avoid a
trade war and that was much appreciated
by businesses across Europe especially
in my own country who relies so much on
trade with the US I mentioned in my own
country Ireland I thank you again for
expressing total solidarity with Ireland
especially in the need to avoid a hard
border and I would appeal to you though
to accompany that with a financial
commitment to help businesses farmers
SMEs who are inevitably going to be
affected one way or the other as a
consequence of private you quoted the
French philosopher saying he liked
things to go together if that solidarity
was went together with a financial
commitment I would be very pleased
especially before the elections because
we all see that it's easier and easier
to in elections by bashing Brussels this
will help to prevent that come on Ultron
Thank You colleagues and I moved to
catch the eye and I will try and take
the maximum number but somebody and many
people may be disappointed please take
two one minutes and I begin by giving
the floor to
mr.christopher oh one minute please
reverie a Miss B step thank you madam
president
we believe and we support the European
Union because we believe that the Union
has a vision and a future and I agree
with the president of the Commission mr.
Juncker saying that we need a strong
European Union but to get a strong
European Union a precondition is that we
defend the rights and the privileges and
the progress of the Member States and we
cannot have a bargain-basement European
Union and we cannot make concessions our
discounts to countries such as Turkey
which does not respect the fundamental
rights of all of the Member States and I
think we've got to defend the rights and
relatives of Member States particularly
those which are under threat from Turkey
and measures must be taken what we
expect from president Younker is to
stand up and tell Turkey respect the
fundamental rights of Cyprus and of
Greece and no discount for the European
perspective for them or anyone else
thank you ok there will be less catch
the eye if everybody goes over one
minute so I will ask you please to stick
to the time mr. Blanco Lopez one minute
please
muchas gracias Senor please thank you
very much president alarm bells are
ringing president things are not looking
good in Europe the extreme right is on
the rise and they're using xenophobic
populist and extremist discourse which
goes against the fundamental values of
the European Union I am concerned that
there is a lack of discourse used to
fight what they say in addition we are
moving forward too slowly we defend
cohesion but we don't
provide the resources necessary we cut
cohesion policy in the CIAP we want to
be leaders in the fight against climate
change but this year emissions have
increased and the resources that we're
going to earmark for the fight against
climate change have been cut president
we want to engage with European citizens
but we need to ensure that words are
accompanied by deeds we need to move
forward on with a social pillar thank
you madam president
we believe any in the European Union of
the nations and the peoples not the
banks not a European Union of banks one
which supports the principle of
subsidiarity and I think that that way
is the best guarantee for peaceful
coexistence in the Europe in the
eurozone we've got to see an end to the
best ability pact which means that
Germany is able to build up enormous
surpluses and we need a decentralized
system of central banks so that the
member states can have their full
economic sovereignty and have a saying
having have a say which is in line with
their I'm a pro rata contribution to the
resources of the European Central Bank
Greece has got special special situation
when it comes to shipbuilding and energy
and animal production and it must be
able to go its own way where appropriate
thank you
microphone please for mrs. moment thank
you very much madam president I'm very
glad that the Commission and committed
president Yonko is giving is proposing
European solutions today those were
ambitious thoughts I think you could be
even more ambitious the level of a
mission could be even higher we're
looking at the qualified majority and I
think we've got to go further when it
comes to external policy and also
defense can I just repeat my own plea
for a European intelligence service in
order to combat terrorism and we have to
crack down on human trafficking in
particular unaccompanied minors they
need special protection and they must
not simply disappear into the woodwork
across Europe we talk about now the end
of the change to summertime well let's
do that and listen let's listen to the
voice of voters and all new citizens
when it comes to summertime listen to
what they're saying so yes these plans
make sure that you deliver on these
let's speed up the passage from the word
studies thank you 11:50 is the time in
Strasbourg 1045 in Portugal Ireland and
the Canary Islands so we have all of
these differences but we have now the
proposal presented by mr. Yonker and I
think this is an opportunity to ensure
that their time zones can be appropriate
this time change had been proposed by
Franco's people said they could adapt to
the time in Nazi Germany then there was
a change in Galicia and in Galicia
actually the time difference between
the actual time and the legal time is
two hours this has consequences on
people's quality of life so I think all
of this situation needs to be deal with
and I think if we harmonize times that's
not good but thank you madam president
president Younker belongs of course to
the EPP and he was speaking as a
European Democrat for the future
looking forwards yesterday mr. Orban
also belongs to the EPP party he talked
about a Europe which was looking
backwards to the Past we prefer the
first vision the first direction and I'd
like to thank mr. president about the
positive things he said about my country
of Greece and I hope that everyone hears
that message in Athens including the
parties of the Opposition who are
currently doom-laden with prophecies of
doom let us do all that we can
everything in our power to build as
broad a pro-european and progressive
coalition as we can in order to not go
down the path of looking back and
turning in which is what the populist
and the extremists want us to do Thank
You mr. Costello
grazie president to you Thank You
president well president Juncker I
listen to your speech very carefully
this year as well and the first thing
that came into mind was a quote from the
gutter Park though we want everything to
change to ensure that everything stays
as it is because once again we're
repeating the same errors your attention
goes to the instruments using rather
than the policies that government them
the migrant crisis you're trying to
explain to citizens how to deal with
that without trying to deal with the
Dublin system and also a system to
manage economic migrants and if we don't
deal
with the problems then we'll simply be
enforcing rules that are anachronistic
and in inappropriate and unfair Dublin
cannot be changed by unanimous voting I
think what we need to do is have big
support from the Commission for those
states who actually demonstrate
solidarity rather than just expressing
solidarity now the change in the time
the change in the clocks that's one
thing that you're doing there speaks
interrupted get here for every thank you
madam president Sam president young
curve in his speech try to embellish
what was happening today in Europe talk
about a united Europe I must say that we
want a Europe of Nations and peoples
that cooperates within its ranks but we
say no when the Union does everything to
erode national sovereignty and we must
make sure that the legitimate interests
of the nations and the peoples are
properly respected we don't want a
multi-speed Europe that is not a success
if certain member states are simply
closing their borders and turning Greece
into a big open air holding camp we
cannot see continued unemployment and
proper ization of entire peoples we
cannot become a global policeman in this
so-called fight against terrorism thank
you sir over
dick weasel any survivors and upon I
said thank you very much and giving me
the floor president of the Commission
I'm very happy to hear you stress that
the Commission's work at the end of your
speech particularly it's working Central
and Eastern Europe security is a major
issue and I also agree with the stress
you put on cooperation with Africa this
too is a very important area of work I
also back the ball string of Frontex
I've seen it firsthand that it's
important that we reinforce this border
guard and give more of resources to its
10,000 employees and also happy that you
enforce you stress the importance of
calling for human rights in China or the
respect of human rights in tuna it's
good to hear the Commission showing a
little more skepticism towards Marx and
Putin thank you very much for your words
mr. Janka let's not forget however that
the Commission still has some work on
his plate cinta young president
president Juncker expressed his love for
Europe's history I share that love but I
would have liked him to give us more of
a symphony in his speech rather than
simply sticking to the basics because
you can't propose new legislation when
you haven't complied with current the
current laws you have and when you can't
ensure that the legislation you're
proposing will actually see the light of
day because we're seeing the erosion of
fundamental rights and an erosion of
trust that's what explains the current
situation now president Juncker
regretted the lack of legal options to
deal with migratory flows but many of us
in this Parliament have been working
hard to ensure that legal ways for
migrant paths to migration are opened
we've been insisting
on this need without support from the
Commission and we've seen resistance
from the council but this was a last
chance commission and we really need to
make sure that we work hard to ensure
that nationalism and populist can't win
the speakers interrupted by the
president
mr. Cecilia Quartus a foot president
thank you madam president the president
young tries to embellish the situation
but the situation is becoming ever more
acute and the economic and political
crisis is becoming more acute on a daily
basis deepening the top priority has to
be making inroads into unemployment and
to increase poverty but what we see
instead of that is an ink reasoning of
the various gaps between different
sections of the community different
parts of the European Union and that's
what gives leverage and attraction to
those on the right who are trying to
divide people and exploit their
disgruntlement which is there in the
inner population and I'm afraid that
we're playing into their hands if we go
for a defense community which is a
fortress which has got a standing army
and which has got bristles with weapons
of the external frontiers we've got to
turn that policy on its head so we have
a one of solidarity peace and less
social injustice thank you very much mr.
Delhi
cousin I ran across one Shawn a lot the
auto quote for Josue president it's a
great shame that
that we didn't hear much about the West
Balkans in mr. yonkers speech we did
hear a lot about the summertime issue
however they could be useful to mention
Belgrade and Pristina Commission's
approaches to those inconsistent and
that's rather reinforcing the status quo
rather than promoting accession I think
we should supporting these negotiating
partners rather than a scare mongering
we need to listen to what they have to
say rather than just ignore it if
there's no uniform support then the
negotiating partners are not going to be
able to move forward and if there's no
result then the whole region will be
unstable demands President Commissioner
timmermans I agree with what you say we
need a united Europe we need a single
currency when he patriotism I think
every member of the European Parliament
would support those things we're hearing
about the summit in Romania but also
we're talking about defending our
foreign borders however how come our
external borders but how can we do that
for example in Romania when we're not
members of the Schengen area Romania
currently satisfies all the conditions
to become a member of Schengen and so it
needs help in addition we'll be they
have the rotating presidency of the
European Council next year and so we'll
have to be a member of Schengen by then
we believe that all countries should be
respected president
mrs. Wu Coonan I was happily off yeah I
think honestly on why not someone you
had to see that
thank you president I agree with the
president of the Commission when he says
that the European Union needs to be
bolstered both in Europe and across the
globe we have a lot of potential at the
international level when it comes to
trade agreements or investment we also
have a role to play in global
development today we need to highlight
the European Union's unity although some
are calling that into question by
turning their backs on the fundamental
values of the European Union those
values are being violated values like
fundamental rights and the rule of law
this effect not just those countries and
their citizens but the whole of the EU
its very nature and the faith that one
can put in the European Union we
discussed this yesterday I think it's
important that we have effective tools
which allow us to act in circumstances
like this and it's a shame to see this
being relevant to a number of member
states at the moment the European can
only function if all of our values and
rights are respected
estimates college I purchase discuss all
donnelly young correctly but she
responsible yep thank you very much and
I'm present the speech today
solidarity well we need that more than
ever before
particularly faced with today's
challenges but I listened to mr. Weber I
think that would simply seek to weaken
the European plan and give extra
ammunition to Euroskeptics and that of
course is not what we want to do mr.
Weber Romania deserves to be in the
Schengen area because Romania has met
all its obligations visa vie
Europe and Romanian citizens have the
same rights as all other European
citizens by the way which you and other
colleagues are attacking Romania only
serves to weaken the competence of
Romanians in the European project and
unfortunately mr. Weber you have turned
the EPP Party into the urban populist
party circuit bro thank you madam
president first of all can I thank
President Juncker for his the kind words
and the sentiments expressed Lisa V
Greece and Greece staying within the
euro however what people listen to the
European Union what it does things which
improve their daily lives and their
bread and butter issues and we are about
to we're working on the MFF the
multi-annual financial framework and
we've got to be competitive horizon
Europe programs such as that have got to
be given proper funding certainly border
guards and we need bodyguards to
supervise our borders but we also need
unified procedures to cope with the
migratory flows that's every bit as
important defends combating
international crime of course that's
important but we need practical measures
which people will thank us for tini
one minute please my pleasure Donnelly
Komisar Verrocchio sup president
commissioner well let me also
congratulate you on your speech mr.
Juncker we need unity prosperity and
many others have already said that as
others have said we also need these
principles to be put into practice but
let me also add that unfortunately until
this point we haven't managed to achieve
the desired cohesion I'd like to thank
mr. Bulman for what he said he said we
have to take
account of Eastern countries they need
to be included rather than stigmatized
as has been happening for far too long
mr. Weber does it for example as part of
his campaign that's been going on for
far too long now we want to ensure there
is fairness and peace within the
European Union Commissioner you know my
country well and I hope you'll take
account of all everything that my
colleagues have said Romania needs to be
part of the Schengen area and it needs
to be made equal with other member
states because we all belong to the same
Club the European Union thank you mr.
Ferrara one minute sir you go to take
your speaking sir 50 seconds tell you if
the bar too good I'm done thank you
hearing this isn't propaganda and I like
it's an attempt to reinforce those who
already in power in citizenship that
you're talking about is citizenship for
the powerful being able to do what they
like in their own interest the military
expenditure has been timed by 20 but mr.
yonkers saying that we're not
militarizing European poll Europe is
imposing underemployment job insecurity
and our employment on its citizens
it's all been fine words but it's really
hiding and ineffectiveness into inaction
this project needs to be undone to
create a Europe for the poor your peace
cooperation and the workers your Melia
godless thank you presents and the
slogans from president Juncker about
competitive he you glow in the global
context really reminds us that we've got
China and Russia the US and they want to
exert control over the energy supply and
over whole continents such as Africa I'm
afraid that the bottom line here is
militarization that's really what this
is about and special majority is
required for cooperative programs
however basically there is an anti
grassroots supervision of the economic
and financial circuits and this means
that the the profit gain is being put
before people profit is being put before
people and this is what the an extreme
nationalist a populist forces are
tapping into and that's where their
strength is coming from currently thank
you very much thank you colleagues that
completes our catch the I I was in the
end able to take everyone who requested
and was in the chamber because the
Commission will not respond in the
debate at this point so we move next to
our groups and begin with the non scree
mr. wolf one minute please thank you
thank you madam president president
Juncker may I congratulate you on your
final State of the Union speech and
whilst many people will be
congratulating you on that and your
vision for the future I just thought it
might be pertinent to remind you of what
actually happened in Europe during your
tenure on the economy we've seen the ik
lapse of many European countries in
youth unemployment in Greece sits at 40
3.2% in Spain 38.8% in Croatia 23.6% in
Greece the children of the
grandchildren's today will still be
paying off the hundred billion the debt
that has been left upon them poverty
misery and sadness covers Europe like a
dark mist of Perpetual pain
whilst in the in the Mediterranean
45,000 bodies will have been buried
there you will have seen millions swarm
into Europe illegally and you have seen
the deaths of four hundred on the
terrorist attacks whilst you and your
fellow unelected colleagues raise a
glass or two to the State of the Union
the rest of Europe will be asking what
is the Union state Thank You mr. Anna
Mons one minute you know um good thank
you very much madam president I think
that the third the Union speech this
year well one of the takeaways of course
is that this is your last State of the
Union speech you have got many admirers
but there was a lot in that about Old
Europe and the your old European Union
what we know need urgently it's a new
European Union because there is the
current one is deeply flawed and it's
got a deeply flawed blueprint as well
more power has been taken into the
European Union that is the wrong way to
go more European citizens want a new
European Union where the peoples and the
nations do not disappear where they
emerged strengthened cosmic political
cost my political open thinking that's
where you're trying to paint the
populist saz as blaggards and that's the
the dominant discourse now but I think
that you've got to look again at what
you've said in this speech and remember
we're preparing for a whole new world
thank you sure you'll kill Monsieur de
menthe
mr. Janka mr. timmermans I'm happy to
see Europeans were happy
to see the end of your term so they
don't have to deal with the Yonkers
elmire double act anymore you've turned
the European Union into something ultra
liberal and the Commission will continue
to create damage to harm if it does that
in your Federalist us you're in denial
and you're engaged in institutional
lying you say you want to risk force the
border on border guards but when France
controllers boarded we did it
effectively you also want the European
Union to get its hands on Foreign
Affairs but that's the last bastion of
major policy eyes remaining in the hands
of the Europe of the Member States you
spout solidarity however your country
mr. Janka has engaged in the worst acts
of fiscal piracy the lux leaks scandal
shows your guilt has been proven stop to
the European disunion I don't want to
see her Frank sit but I'm also against
your utopian view of United States of
Europe we don't want to see any African
ization of Europe Islamic terrorism
globalism and the pillage by the
multinationals and the internet Giants
we want an independent European nations
protecting its peoples and we will have
that mrs. Zimmer one minute please
oh she must in your gun squats
well just very briefly I wanted to take
the floor once again we heard Mr Yonkers
responses to our initial statements and
he was talking about the social pillar
particularly when it came to introducing
guarantees for children in all member
states of the European Union but I just
want to say that the treaties do give
the possibility of an eu-wide minimum
income that can be dealt with at the
European level there are initiatives
already been carried out on homeless
people and on those living in poverty
and this is coming onto the agenda in
all Member States now so we would
appreciate a proposal from the European
Commission on a
minimum income for citizens right across
Europe
thank you one minute mr. Torvald thank
you madam president
you can be an european patriot and a
finnish patient you can be a european
patriot and a hungarian patriot but you
can't be a european patriot and a
nationalist that doesn't go together
jean-claude Juncker spoke very nicely
about his love affair with Europe we all
know that love affairs are difficult
that goes with you with European love
affairs ago the Finnish love affair that
goes with Hungarian love affairs but
rather affairs needs possibilities
ability to make decisions if we can't
make the decisions about our love
affairs we're gonna lose this out and
therefore I all for love affairs but I'm
all for decisions and I think show
include quad for his nice words about
his love affair with Europe thank you
thank you mr. Kemal for three and a half
minutes thank you very much
at its heart today's State of the Union
was actually an appraisal of the
Commission of us in this Parliament and
of the whole European Union and too
often when we were wrapped in our bubble
of commentators blogs news cycles and
work programmes we often forget that it
is the people the taxpayers and the
voters that we serve and not the other
way round but we hear many in this
chamber tell voters that their concerns
are unfounded or that they have that the
way they have chosen to vote is
nationalistic or populist but by
attempting to shut out parties that who
do not share their vision and do not
believe in the project they also shut up
many voters and push them further away
now I know that mr. Yunker has worked
very hard to regain the competence of
voters but many people in many EU Member
States feel that the EU has lost its way
that it has failed to deliver on issues
such as jobs it is failed to deliver on
their concerns over migration is failed
to deliver on them feeling safer in
their in their home countries and on the
things that they care about so when
politicians here talk about winning back
their confidence it rings hollow to
those that are still willing to listen
as they feel that they have heard it all
before
now I remember only too well into 2014
as president yonk addressed this chamber
full of freshly elected MVPs declare it
to be a moment to be a new start for
Europe and said that we should play as a
team with common policies yet voters
have seen attempts to push that divisive
migration policies and sadly rather than
helping people have reduced some
sympathy in some quarters for refugees
and those themed war and persecution
rather than what going around the table
and asked in each country what they can
do rather than tell them what to do you
spoke of greater transparency but the
public reading the papers of the
appointment of a commission safety
general that was clouded in secrecy he
said that Europe cannot spend money that
it does not have but see a multi annual
budget demanding more money at a time
when one of the largest net contributors
is leaving he talked about considering
given the eurozone its own budget
capacity and powers but as the people of
Germany will tell you there is no such
thing as European money my group agrees
with mr. Younker when he said we don't
need a European solution to everything
and this is still the case so European
conservatives and reformists ask that
this commission president and the Fuji
Commission presence listen to the people
who have lost confidence in the EU now I
know at times of our group can be the
greatest critics but real friends tell
each other the hard truths and we work
together where we agree so the ECR calls
to start people on the commission start
to live in the kind of view opinion that
people want and deserve not an EU which
increasingly replaces national
governments not not not a European Union
that is dismantled destroyed but a
reformed European Union that mr. Yunker
promised to deliver here in this chamber
five years ago with vital elections next
year this is the 11th hour for the EU it
is time to move on from the nineteen
fifties model of a federalized EU an
outdated vision of yester
and it's time to deliver an e you shaped
by the wishes of its peoples those who
want a better tomorrow thank you
two minutes mr. Bullen thank you these
are it but that get psyched this debate
has shown that we need to reinforce
citizen's confidence in the European
Union and so I turn to the Commission
and say that I think there has to be
some upshot from this discussion we've
said that we need a basic guarantee for
every child in the European Union the
president has said that he would make
sure an initiative was begun and I will
make sure I'll keep an eye on that we've
said that we have to ensure the rights
of people on internet platforms for us
it's entirely unacceptable that in most
EU countries women earn less for the
same work than men
when will the Commission be coming
forward to the proposal to counter that
miss Simha is right saying we need a
framework directive guaranteeing a
minimum income in Europe that is
essential if we are to bridge the
disparities in the single market we've
said that we want to become more
sustainable and to create a new economic
model that has to be visible in the
European semester the figures have to
tell the truth about our environmental
consumption that employment reform the
European semester and give us the
possibility to make progress in the
monetary and economic union so that the
opinion can actually be capable of
meaningful action we've called on the
Commission to be active in fighting
against cyber criminality I'm happy to
hear mr. Yonkers say that he will
take initiatives but I would call on the
Austrian presidency and say the
following in December you have a special
summit why not appeal to all of the
Member States to take steps to make sure
that the European elections next year
are secure and can't be manipulated by
third parties now is the time to act the
Austrian presidency is responsible for
this special summit making real progress
particularly for example in rescuing
people on the high seas it's a scandal
what's happening on my season I hope
that you'll be I'll take some initiative
thank you thank you mr. Weber the
president in lyrically gonna colleague
or kick me some slows me speed up
president colleagues will I'd also like
to thank you for the constructive
discussion that we've had and we are
pleased to find the Commission in work
mode the European Parliament I think can
also be proud of what we've done and
what we're proposing but so there's one
thing that's very important in 2018 we
must ensure that we provide answers to
the migration issue because otherwise
citizens will be saying why there's
nothing we done been done why haven't we
been able to deal with this issue so I
think that has to be our top priority
now when it comes to the future let me
just take a couple of points from the
state to the Union speech that I think
are important firstly security the
feeling of security that people have and
secondly fairness in Europe we need a
new approach to fairness in a digital
world and to conclude president during
the first round of speakers there was a
debate as to whether the crisis had been
overcome or not whether the problems had
been resolved or not where there was a
lot to do or not I think we will only be
able to convince people in Europe when
we're optimistic we need to be able to
say that we are in the situation to deal
with problems that we can solve their
challenges and we can be proud of what
we're doing thank you very much
Thank You colleagues that concludes our
debate on the state of the union we will
have a short recess and votes will begin
at 12:30 thank you